so we recently got our hands on coding
scheme it's a cute little RTS sort of
turn-based role-playing game from
intelligent systems the team behind Fire
Emblem games and it's for nintendo 3ds
and we looked at the multiplayer mode
yeah and it for me it's fun i played
this a few times already and into the
art style the story it's all really
ridiculous I mean it's not captured by
the name code name z which is not a that
it doesn't encapsulate the fact that
steampunk Abraham Lincoln is sitting a
Catman and Tom Sawyer on a mission to
fight aliens yeah because I like that's
just a ridiculous fun story and it's
from the fire of them team like they
know how to do RTS games and you would
think that they're going to put together
a really fun solid system but it's a
very very different system you're
someone who's played a lot of fire of
love oh yeah I play firing limb
awakening and I loved it and I do enjoy
this this is more like a melding a fire
awakening strategy elements with McKenna
like a third-person shooter so I am I am
obsessed with Fire Emblem i love that
seriously death but I feel like
codenames team took out a lot of the
elements that made fire emblem work so
well I know there's no when you're in
matches whether it's in you know in
single player or in multiplayer there's
no map like there's no you can't pull
out and look at the whole map and see
your enemy placement you sort of start
out start out in one section of a map
and you can only see what your four
characters see so you have a very
limited field of view and then once your
turn is up and they're taking their turn
like whether it's you know again the
aliens a single player your opponent in
multiplayer you can't really you can't
really see them I ran into a lot of
problems where I was either facing a
wall when I stopped I was facing
something and I couldn't really move the
camera to see what was going on so it
was 60 seconds of like dramatic music
and people shouting oh there's aliens
and I can't see them and that really
frustrated me yeah it's turn based
strategy so in between those turns you
do switch between you can switch between
your characters and you have a limited
field of view where you can kind of move
the camera around and maybe good a
glimpse of somebody but you'll also you
do get audible cues when one of your
characters see somebody you just have to
know like oh that was that person's
voice and he just saw someone else in
the distance while switch my camera to
them
and try to get income through what
they're doing as someone like I do like
RTS games and I do prefer having that
map that gives me that overhead view so
like I can strategize more and it felt
like a very different way to approach
this I mean you'd have to get used like
this is something that you're not gonna
be able to jump into necessarily you
have to play multiple rounds get used to
the map cuz otherwise someone who does
know how to play it who's just really
use of that map is just gonna squash you
it's like a like a regular shooter yeah
they know where to go they know how to
set up their team and flank you and go
around whereas otherwise you're going in
lines that you don't know what anything
around you is but and there are a lot of
things which kind of change up between
the matches that you know the layout
will be the same each time but when you
hit barrels and boxes or items that will
buff your character like quite a bit
like those can be really really helpful
and those are going to be different
every time but sometimes those barrels
actually explode and hurt you a lot yeah
see I ran I ran into that problem i also
ran into another problem with them with
the characters you can choose you know
the further they have their primary
weapon and then you can choose a
secondary weapon and some of the weapons
let you actually shoot like like like
med grenades like you can heal people in
a certain radius or heal one character
or you can like catapult like I think my
favorite weapon was the bear catapult
you just shoot a bear and then there's
the one where you can like shoot
mechanical penguins and they come out or
whatever and they explode I mean I
definitely had a little bit of an
advantage because I played the game
enough to know what all the basic
weapons were and and we were jumping
into the middle of the game so there
were a lot of options and that's
actually something that excites me a
little bit more cuz I I love going
through the menu and the options like
your primary weapon has always stuck to
your character you get to choose your
secondary weapon so you you really have
to know what your primary is going in
then that way you can choose from the
list of secondary weapons and then also
the steam pack on your back that that
affects things in another way and like I
love those that level of customization
and like you mentioned like some
different weapons and those different
effects like shooting little penguins
out and have a little model and explode
on an enemy I don't know I couldn't like
I was getting very frustrated and having
that 60-second span where my enemy was
taking his turn and I was switching
between four characters and not really
able to see what was going on that
really frustrated me and I think I like
I died a lot but I couldn't like get
used to the idea of like I can't see
what's going on under 18
so I don't know it'll be really
interesting to see how well this game
catches on because obviously it has to
go after those Fire Emblem fans it's by
that developer it's an RTS but at the
same time it's really really different
and it's not gonna be going after that
same audience in some ways its steampunk
it's more modern it's absolutely batshit
insane it's super weird I like it I
think it's endearing okay well we'll see
I guess we will see I'm gonna lean it
back on this beanbag goodnight
you